Statisticians have determined three conventional levels of likelihood, or
should I say unlikelihood. If the probability of getting a sample mean is less
than 0.05, or 5%, 0.01 or 1%, or 0.001, which is 0.1% then it's usually
considered unlikely. Getting a probability less than 0.1% is just very
unlikely. These are called the alpha levels. Now let's just take a quick quiz
to make sure you understand what alpha levels are. Let's focus on an alpha
level of 0.05. Which of the following are true? If the probability of getting a
particular sample mean is less than alpha, it is unlikely to occur. For this
next option, let's say that the z-score here, cutting off the top 5%, is z
star. If a sample mean has a z-score greater than z star, it is unlikely to
occur. Your third option is if the probability of getting a particular sample
mean is unlikely. The sample mean is in the orange region. And finally the
alpha level corresponds to the orange region. True or not? Check all that
apply.